hey what's going on everyone it's axel
here for anime uproar and today i will
be discussing some of the strongest
characters in the jujutsu kaizen world
the special class sorcerers these are
some of the most
interesting and unique people in the
story so far
and while we haven't had too many
interactions with most of them
we have seen each of them in action at
least once
and it's always a treat when we do see
them if you enjoy this video and want to
see more jujutsu kaizen content on this
channel be sure to leave a like and a
comment with who you think i should talk
about
next it'll only take a second but it is
a huge help for the channel and hey
if you haven't subscribed to anime
uproar make this the video that you do
and be sure to click that bell and
select all notifications
you can also follow anime uproar on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar or
you can follow myself
at excellionyt finally this video will
contain jutsukai's and manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
much like curses sorcerers also work on
a grade based system
and typically it's the case that a
sorcerer in a specific grade will be
sent to fight curses of a relatively
similar grade
so before we get into these special
grade sorcerers themselves let's take a
quick look at what the grades correlate
to at least
loosely a grade 4 curse is supposed to
be able to be taken down by a wooden bat
so sorcerers of this grade are likely
around that power level
ironically the only sorcerer we know of
in this rank is maki zenin
and that was only because her family
held her back from promotions
but as we saw in the most recent chapter
chapter 152
i don't think the zenin clan will be
speaking up against her all that much
going forward
the few who are left alive probably
recognize how strong she is at this
point
and if i had to guess i'd say she would
probably be upped to at least
special grade 1 if not special grade
herself
grade 3 curses can be dealt with easily
if you have a handgun and our sorcerers
at this rank
include nobara kugisaki mai zenin and
kasumi miwa
obviously mai is no longer able to be a
sorcerer because
of current manga events and nobara is
kind of
unclear at this moment so this grade
definitely needs an
update at grade 2 you are lucky to beat
the curse if you have a shotgun
you're looking at sorcerers like
takumaino megumi fushiguro
panda and momonishinia grade ones are
where things start to get very serious
in most cases they're tank level or
above we currently have five grade one
sorcerers
although we definitely need an update
here as well
these are kentonami naimei alitoro
atsuya kusukawe and masamichi yaga
however
we also have four sorcerers who are
semi-grade one
these are basically between grade two
and one
they're just kind of waiting to pass
some tests or they're sort of in the
middle of training to really earn that
full rank up
these being toge inumaki noritoshikamo
kokichi muta and utahime iori while
these four
are on their way to being grade ones
there's still a pretty significant gap
between their power levels and those who
are actually great ones
similarly there is another gap between
grade ones and special grade ones
we only know of four special grade ones
to this point and they are now beto
zenin
naoya zenin jinichi zenin and ogie zenin
these were each the highest members of
the zenin family however
i believe that only nawya is alive at
this point
and that's mostly a result of maki's
actions so i would assume she should be
at least here
and finally that brings us to the big
ones the special grade
where cluster bombs might work all of
these are so far above the others that
we've mentioned so far it just kind of
isn't even fair to compare them
the four special grade sorcerers that we
know about so far
are satoru gojo tsugeru ghetto yuki
tsukumo
and yuta okutsu gojo obviously being on
his own level even
among this group and that kind of brings
up the difficulty in understanding this
rank because it's kind of just cluster
bomb or up with no real
upper limit so while someone who was as
strong as a nuke
might also be in this group there's a
big difference between them
and that cluster bomb you know but
essentially the special grade sources
are just that they're special
they're hard to define they're just more
than what is typically possible
to a normal sorcerer so what exactly can
these four special grade sorcerers do
well we already have a whole video on
gojo which you can check out in the
pinned comments and the card
however i'm still covering him briefly
here gojo's ability is
limitless and it allows him to control
the space around him
this typically manifests in three ways
for those who have this ability
firstly being infinity an invisible aura
that they can keep around themselves at
all times
which slows any approaching object to
the point that they seem to not move
he can obviously choose who's affected
by this or he would never be able to
hold hands or give someone a high five
however it is mostly automatic at this
point and is able to detect the velocity
size and general threat level of
whatever's approaching him
he did say that he wants to build up
this skill so it could detect poison in
the future though so it isn't
a perfect or flawless system as it is
and it is something that he can still
train
the second use is manifesting limitless
through curse technique lapse blue
a pulling force that draws things in by
creating a vacuum
using negative cursed energy essentially
he removes everything from a certain
section of space
and the world corrects this by pulling
things into that space
this can be amplified into curse
technique lapse maximum cursed energy
output blue which is a mouthful to say
but this will allow gojo to create a
mini black hole that he can move around
at his own discretion then he has curse
technique reversal red
rather than blue's pulling force red is
a massive pushing force
which seems to be just a huge laser
finally
an exclusive gojo ability is combining
reds pushing and blues pulling to create
hollow purple
with this gojo creates a singularity
that destroys everything it touches to
the molecular level
of course gojo also has access to his
domain expansion
unlimited void which overwhelms his
targets with so much information and so
many experiences that they can't even
move
leaving them effectively as a sitting
duck but through all of these amazing
things he can do the most
important thing is the six eyes this
raises his level of perception
and allows him to even see a target's
amount of cursed energy
but most importantly it drastically
reduces the amount of cost
that's associated with each cursed
energy ability the reason this is such a
huge deal
is because while gojo has these crazy
powerful techniques
he would have a limit to how much he
could use them without the six eyes
whereas now he's able to use them near
endlessly
like i said though we talked about gojo
in more depth a few weeks ago and if
you're interested you can check out that
video as well
next up we have one of my own personal
favorite sorcerers
suguru ghetto way back before gojo had
fully mastered his abilities
it was said that he and ghetto were
fairly close in terms of power
of course ghetto is no longer really in
the picture
but even after having his body stolen
his abilities are still
fairly similar ghetto's main ability is
cursed spirit manipulation
this allows him to more or less become
the pokemon trainer of the jujutsu
kaizen world
he can absorb cursed spirits into a
black orb which he swallows for storage
and regurgitates for usage
which gross but regardless of how gross
it is
weak curses can be controlled with no
issues while larger ones can be a bit
more stressful for him
typically he doesn't summon too many
curses at once however
if he's in a pinch he can use maximum
uzumaki
his strongest ability to date and we
have seen him summon up to over
4 000 curses with this which again
if we compare him to megumi who is a
pretty similar style of sorcerer
both summoning things in some way or
another you could just see this massive
gap between a special grade sorcerer and
a grade 2
sorcerer ghetto is only limited by the
types and amounts of curses that he's
able to collect
and i guess if he has enough badges to
train the ones he collects
where the pokemon parallels stop though
is that ghetto is able to steal curses
from other sorcerers as long as he kills
their owners before he tries to absorb
them into his orb
which now that i think about it could
you steal someone's pokemon if their
owner died
man team rocket should have just done
that from the start huh next up we have
yuta
okotsu one of his greatest strengths is
his ability to control cursed energy
basically he's able to use his cursed
energy in a way that is more effective
than just about anyone else in the
series
other than maybe characters like gojo or
sukuna in the most basic ways this means
that he can reinforce his body in a
fight lowering the amount of damage that
he takes by hardening his body to the
point that he can't be injured
or by supplementing his own attacks to
make them extremely powerful
it also ensures that his reverse curse
technique can do some immense healing
and then we have his actual abilities
while
inconsistent he can sometimes summon
rika
who was one of the most powerful cursed
spirits of all time
so much so that it was able to overwhelm
and defeat
all of the curses in ghetto's maximum
uzumaki
he also seems to have a very unique
ability to copy
other people's techniques at least at a
very general and basic level
we even see him using this to use the
toge clan's
exclusive cursed speech ability however
again
it doesn't seem like he can fully
control this it's not a perfect copy
but it is still functionable yuta kind
of seems like the jack of all trades
sort of character
he can kind of do everything in a good
enough sort of way but really excels in
the basics
throw a nearly unstoppable cursed spirit
into that mix and you have an all-around
pretty great character and finally we
have yuki tsukumo
we know very little about her so far
however we do know
three things firstly she was a mentor to
aoi toto
which when you consider how powerful
toto is that's
pretty impressive second she is strong
enough to stop
powerful cursed user abilities like
uraune's icefall
with what looked like zero effort and
third
i mean she kind of waifu material
give me more women who could beat me up
gage i demand it they fuel me
unfortunately though this is kind of all
that we have about tsukumo at this point
in the story
i'm sure we will get more as it
continues but what do you guys think of
our four
special grade sorcerers obviously i
would think gojo
is the strongest but of the next three
who do you think follows up
and which of them is your favorite be
sure to let me know your thoughts in the
comments section down below
as well as what other jujutsu kaizen
videos you'd like to see me make in the
future
if you guys enjoyed this jujutsu kaizen
video though and want to see more please
leave a like and if you're new to anime
uproar remember to subscribe and ring
that bell
by selecting all notifications you can
help guarantee that you will not miss
any of our future videos i know it's a
hassle but because of how youtube works
you gotta click the bell that being said
like i mentioned earlier we also have a
video on gojo's abilities that went up a
little while ago
you can check that out if you're
interested and of course you can follow
anime uproar
at anime uproar on twitter or instagram
or myself
excellionyt i want to give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar patrons
for making videos like this one possible
a special thank you to the absolute mad
lad and disciple of lord twigo himself
alpha sigma and of course all of our the
one tier patrons the ones who stand
above
all other clans ingrata pateh
al-jital dr kortman the toasted chi
the spike 8227 emperor otaku
spidey life tinel tungsten tarkus
faked buddhist cody hebert and monkey d
quilly
and of course i want to thank our pro
hero patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh
the red haired raven angel cruz anatoly
kozitsky
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water
joanne garcia ted not ted fatboy games
corey mcgowan metal mama deadly saint
soul ride slice and dice
if you're enjoying our videos and feel
like they're adding some level of value
to your life
please consider supporting us over on
patreon even a dollar gives you access
to our patron exclusive discord
and we'll get your name in all of our
videos along with these fantastic people
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time
stay excellent
[Music]